ciao ragazzi scusate se faccio questo
video solamente adesso ma in realtà di
questo weekend sono stato a milano con
il mio ragazzo e quindi non sono state
da tanto dietro i commenti che ho
ricevuto sotto l'ultimo video
ora devo dire che di base il video come
sempre è piaciuto e di questo sono
contento ma ho notato che ho ricevuto
anche delle critiche delle critiche da
parte di alcune persone che volevano
delle spiegazioni riguardo a quello che
è stato il mio linguaggio nell'ultimo
video perché alcuni commenti sono
passati come commenti transfobici ora
inizialmente quello che ho fatto è stato
semplicemente rispondere direttamente
alle persone pensando che comunque fosse
una cosa molto più più piccole più
semplice finché a un certo punto l'ho
iniziato a ricevere delle critiche più
pesanti in cina sulla torta poi è stato
un video che ho ricevuto tramite
instagram è guardato ed era di una
persona che era molto molto raffinata e
che mi attaccava in in maniera
abbastanza violenta
paragonando comunque i commenti avevo
fatto io a dire [ __ ] di merda o al
dire a un da una persona su una
carrozzina alzati allora delle ho detto
cacchio se veramente è passato questo
messaggio addirittura così grave da me
preme per fare chiarezza e soprattutto
chiedere scusa ho chiesto dei pareri a
chi mi stava vicino cioè che diceva ma
no la sua star sono pochissime comunque
le persone che stanno lottando questa
cosa fare catene però io non ce la
faccio non ce la faccio perché a me va
benissimo ricevere delle critiche da
parte che ne so di di persone che sono
molto bene di persone che che non sono
d'accordo con quelli persone ideali ci
sta lo penso e quindi allo stesso tempo
mi apro delle critiche a volte faccio un
po da pungiball ricevere delle critiche
per qualcosa che io non penso ma ho
fatto proprio pensare cazzo hai dopo
sbagliato tutto e nel momento in cui a
farti una critica è più di una persona
forse un fondo di verità c'è per essere
diciamo chiaro al cento per cento
cercherò di leggere alcuni dei commenti
che che mi sono arrivati che mi hanno
fatto pensare ok forse hai un attimo
pestato una merda
gu io ti voglio bene ma dire un trans e
la sorpresina sono commenti transfobici
osseo e offensivi come prossimo tema di
vita buttata vorrei scuse dovute a
partire dalla tua per la trans france
fobia di questo video magari non
strapperà
risata facile come le battute sulle pre
sorpresine forse non farà ridere ha
fatto ma avrà contribuito a rendere il
mondo un posto un pochino migliore un po
più rispettoso per le persone
transgender un po più informato sono
sicura che questo modo di parlare sia
scaturito dall ambiente culturale in cui
è emersa l'italia e che non ci sia
nessuna malafede
per questo spero davvero che le tue
scuse alla comunità transgender
arriveranno
mi dispiace perché sono consapevole che
certe affermazioni si dicono senza
pensarci su soprattutto quando produce
video molto spontanee come questi
purtroppo però fu se un produttore di
contenuti e molta gente ti segue
dovresti essere più attento quando dice
certe cose mi riferisco a un trans
ferito ad una mmf e sorpresi in antiche
sarebbe meglio film e già si fa fatica a
sensibilizzare su certi temi
e tu che appartiene alla comunità di
legge picchi dovresti saperlo non
metterti c'è anche tu ad insegnare alle
persone che meno sanno concetti
sbagliati che non aiutano a migliorare
la vita delle persone trans
io provo per te una stima infinita
davvero però forse le prime due battute
e transfobiche magari meglio di no mi
dispiace vogliamo ma sei sempre stato
simpatico questa volta è sbagliato di
grosso non far ridere parlare di trans
non è accettabile chiamare una donna
trance col maschile nel ridere nel
ridere della donna con sorpresa una
donna trans non a sorpresa e una donna a
tutti gli effetti metterlo nel video
ridere di gusto a chiamarla al maschile
e transfobico è inaccettabile e va
contro tutti i bei discorsi tolleranza
che hai fatto
la comunità lgbt non è fatta solo da
omosessuali spero tutti renda conto
dell'errore commesso ti informi e che la
cosa non si ripeta più è una grande
responsabilità con una piattaforma così
grande usata bene di base avete avete
capito ancora io ci tengo subito a
chiarire un punto io chiedo scusa ma vi
prego di non farmi chiedere scusa per la
mia transfobia trans ma cosa e
transfobia perché non sono transfobico
cioè chiedere scusa per una cosa che non
sono vi chiedo piuttosto scusa per la
minoranza per quanto riguarda il primo
commento io vi chiedo perdono
ma a me appena siamo arrivati al cuoco
cioè io non c'è più visto
a me faceva troppo ridere questa questo
quadretto quindi in quel momento ridendo
come madre che militava vicino io non è
che ho pensato a facciamo un attimo un
pochino di sensibilizzazione non è
giusto dire un trans a parte che io
ancora non ho capito se era una trans un
travestito
perché dice uno con la parrucca un trans
con la parrucca boh non lo so in quanto
sbagliando un [ __ ] cioè non è che ho
pensato facciamo un attimo un pochino di
sensibilizzazione spieghiamo che ho è
una trans o un travestito
per quanto invece riguarda alcuni
messaggi che mi sono arrivati dove
dicevano sì ma comunque molto brutto far
passare una transessuale come una poco
di buono che sta a letto con 1 ora
ragazzi a me dispiace questo però in
quel momento cioè se io fossi stato
la ragazza è entrata e se mi becco il
mio ragazzo con la mia migliore amica
con una transessuale un travestito io
ancora non l'ho capito
è un cuoco c'è io vorrei bruciando tutti
e quattro al di là di quello che possono
essere il re razze sesso e orientamento
quindi non so quanto possa essere un
accezione negativa una storia di vita
vissuta
se non effettivamente per l'errore
enorme per cui [ __ ] io
l'articolo maschile coronamento è fan
non si mette mette invece per quanto
riguarda il secondo commento ci tengo
innanzitutto a dire una cosa io e mia
madre non stavamo ridendo per l'aneddoto
in sé
stiamo ridendo perché lo si vede pure la
ragazza che raccontava la storia sembra
con un piede nella fossa cioè sembrava
che stesse per esalare l'ultimo respiro
poi io chiedo scusa chiedo scusa perché
questa ignoranza crassa avevo vicino a
mia mamma che non l'ha capito la storia
e quando uno ha chiesto di raccontarle
qual era il problema della ragazza io
l'ho detto guarda il problema di questa
ragazza che si è seduta sulle gambe di
una ragazza che però poi ho scoperto
avere una sorpresina
io vi giuro p giuro non pensavo che dire
una sorpresina potesse risultare così
offensivo altimenti fico che il caso
sono uno stronzo che lo dicevo ho
cercato di diciamo utilizzare sorpresi
in al posto del
ho ricevuto anche dei commenti una
persona che diceva scusa ma che è un
appestato una trans ed eviti può
scappare bloccarlo ovunque fuggire non
ho capito e devo dire che l'unica cosa
che in quel momento che mi è venuto in
mente mentre sentivo il commento
quello che ho pensato però sul momento è
non so forse questa ragazza è rimasta
male per il modo in cui l'ha scoperto
magari si aspettava che ci fosse una
chiacchiera che le venisse detto a voce
prima di scoprirlo in questo modo non lo
so in quel momento
scusate non lo so in quel momento non mi
è venuto di chiarire questo punto ho
sbagliato assolutamente chiedo scusa più
che altro mi dispiace proprio mi
dispiace perché odio deludere
eccole le persone perché un conto è
veramente ricevere una critica da parte
di chi sa che ti criticano apre una cosa
che pensi continua ribadirlo odio riceve
una critica per una cosa che non penso
ma che ho detto perché perché sono stato
un [ __ ] e non sono un trans fobico
continua a dirlo mi sento pure stupida
doverlo specificare questa cosa vi
chiedo scusa per i commenti
profondamente ignoranti vi prego di
prenderli per questo bbb supplico e anzi
sarò attentissimo vi prometto che
cercherò di rifarci ancora più
attenzione perché sono state nelle
leggerezze che non posso assolutamente
permettermi e che non devo assolutamente
permettermi di avere il momento in cui
possono effettivamente ferire così tanto
e mi addolora enormemente
scusatemi se non sono con le lacrime
però io in realtà sotto sotto sono
contento che grazie a un errore
madornale se è uscito anche la
possibilità di iniziare ad aprire questo
questo tema quindi tutto sommato queste
critiche anche le più dure in realtà
sono servite a farmi un attimo aprire
gli occhi a farmi effettivamente capire
che nel momento in cui si parla di
transessuali
bisogna effettivamente mettere i guanti
di velluto e questa è una cosa
importante direbbe anche di gioia mi
riempì anche di di orgoglio per quella
che è la comunità lgbt che è così
attenta a queste cose ti giuro che non
ho minimamente pensato adesso sto
transessuale con la parrucca la
sorpresina
io ribadisco c'è stato chi mi ha
definito il paladino della giustizia in
maniera negativa
ora io non sono il padrino di un di un
cazzo ve lo dico proprio tranquillamente
perché perché secondo me non deve
servire essere omosessuali per difendere
i diritti dei gay con non deve servire
essere transessuali per difendere quelli
dei trans
spero che qualora fossi nato etero
avrebbe comunque avuto un'apertura
mentale che mi avrebbe spinto a pensare
che effettivamente ogni persona ogni
singola anima abbia bisogno di amare
bisogno di ricevere amore in egual
misura rispetto a chiunque altro sulla
faccia del pianeta
quindi sappiate che da questa parte
avrete sempre un alleato che gli sta
chiedendo scusa veramente al profondo
del suo cuore e che soprattutto spera
che possiate accettarle capire che è
stato un [ __ ] se invece queste scuse
non vi basteranno spero in futuro di
fare un qualcosa che vi faccia ricredere
a quelle che sono le parole che ho detto
in questo video che sono un pochino
uscite così in maniera spontanea ma un
pochino così cercato di dire uno che mi
veniva che mi passava per la testa spero
di aver coperto tutto quello che c'era
da coprire erano oneste
ecco non servono per accattivare nessuno
anche perché se avessi voluto
accattivare persone
il fatto roaming out detto ciò io spero
di poter aprire questo dibattito più in
avanti e magari che ne so parlarne anche
con persone che ne sanno molto più di me
io che dire credo spero di aver detto
tutto di uno spegne videocamere di
roccazzo potevi dire pure quest altra
cosa un puzzle e al prossimo video